and never look
backs and simply learn to get
ahead a civil engineer turned data
scientist who decided to Simply learn
possible with a course from a premier
[Music]
University true champion who upskilled
to win big
how big a massive hike that transformed
my life Danish change gears pretty early
in the race but pron wanted to explore
more to get ahead isar simply learn from
mechanical engineering to a data analyst
and a podcaster in his free time
transformation simply learn industry
expert data
expert with a well structured course it
felt like a piece of cake that is simply
awesome what's also awesome is that long
didn't choose a quick fix he just added
data science into the
mix Nathan how did you change the game
worked on real industry problems to
become the real deal a joint family a
regular job responsibilities but nothing
could stop nin from getting ahead what
an allrounder day night with flexible
learning you can always make it right
passion
situation
you tooo will find your way to get ahead
when you simply
learn simply learn get ahead with simply
[Music]
Lear
with the city the state and the country
you are joining us
from the chat is
open hi
majit India Bangalore for
Texas was son from Bangalore
love from
[Music]
Canada
Pakistan Canada
Estonia great great great we have a wide
set of audience today Brian it's great
yeah now o are you gonna share where
you're
from uh so I from Simply learn I am
based in Bangalore India uh what about
you Brian I'm a Houston Tex us now
what's what's the weather like in in
Bangalore this evening is it uh
Bangalore is pretty cool right now it
had a light sh in the evening and so
it's pretty much pleas that's great to
hear
nice I would request all of you to put
in your questions in the Q&A
box and we'll be answering them
throughout the session
today so let's get started first let me
set up some ground rules for the
audience uh please put your questions in
the Q&A box please do not put it in the
chat box as we might lose track of them
uh the session is being recorded so
you'll be getting a followup email with
the recording link as well as the
webinar certificate and the bonus
offer uh in order to request the proof
of attendance you will need to stay till
the end of the webinar and and fill in
the end post webinar survey which will
be presented to you after you leave the
webinar
today first let me introduce uh myself
my name is aay I am from Simply learn
Bangalore India uh we are we are the
world's number one online boot camp we
have been in the industry of digital
skills training for over 13 years now
and we have uh trained over 5 million
professionals across the globe in over
150 countries so that's what we are here
to present today and before we begin
I'll have a quick poll questions uh we
just want to know how many years of
experience do our audience have today uh
you may be 0 to two years 3 to 5 years 5
to 10 years or more than 10 years I'll
quickly launch the poll so you can put
punch in your answers I would request
all the participants to punch in their
answers great great great we have a very
engaging audience today I hope this
energy goes on till the end of the
webinar I'll keep the poll open for
another 5 seconds and I'll end the
poll thank you all for your response uh
as I can see Brian uh more than 55% of
our audience have more than 5 years of
experience right and 16% are still
studying and about 30% are between uh
zero to five years of
experience wonderful
okay moving
on uh let's get to the agenda of the
webinar today we'll be talking about you
uh then we'll have a short project demo
by Brian where you'll learn lean Ops for
a superior customer service for leading
entertainment company uh we will have
the pr program induction for the
postgraduate program in Lan Sigma and
we'll also run you through the
enrollment steps pretty quickly and
we'll have a Q&A session at the end of
the session where uh we will taking your
questions introducing our Mentor for
today we have Mr Brian Campbell he has
been in the industry of project
management and program management for
over 25 years and he has been associated
with simply learn for over 10 years and
has been a mentor and trainer at simply
learn I would request Brian to introduce
himself today yeah thanks so much sh
it's great to be part of the session so
uh yeah as you can see I have a lot of
experienced background in Project
program management um and a big part of
that actually is leveraging lean
practices so we spend a lot of time in
Project program management uh trying to
understand how to increase throughput
remove waste so we can deliver more
value so uh as a result I've been
spending a lot of time uh with with lean
and S Sigma I also teach courses in that
space and today we're going to spend
some time looking at a real world
example how you can apply these
techniques to help an organization
unlock and deliver more value great
great thank you Brian and Welcome to our
session
today uh before we begin with the live
project demo I would like to run another
poll uh just to understand why our
audience is here today uh you may be
looking for a
may be looking to become a lean6 sigma
professional you want to learn a new
skill or you may be here to understand
if it's easy to learn lean6 Sigma or are
you interested in working on new
projects which we can add to your
portfolio I quickly launch the poll
please punch in your answers so that we
can have an idea of what our audience is
looking for today before we
begin
I'll keep the poll open for another 10
seconds so you can punch in your
answers I would request all of you to
punch in your answers in the
PO great great great thank you all for
your responses as I can see Brian most
of them here to learn a new skill uh
some of them are looking for working new
on projects for their
portfolio some to understand what how is
L Sigma is it easy to
learn and majority are you to become a
LMA
profession okay thank you for your
responses now I would uh request Brian
to take up and take over from our
presentation and
teachers go take us through the live
project I'll just stop sharing my screen
okay
yeah thanks so much AE and welcome
everyone I know you're very interested
in kind of seeing a little bit more
directly how can you apply some of these
ideas and Concepts like lean and Six
Sigma to a real world business
environment so um just a few things as
as a kind of you know shape what we're
going to be spending some time on what
I'm going to do is I'm going to actually
show you uh an existing case study and
we're going to look at that together
much as you would if you were taking one
of the uh courses and programs offered
by simply learned the University of
Massachusetts and really use that as a
means to kind of identify this is what
these techniques look like hopefully
demystify them a little bit and to give
you a sense that hey these are quite
accessible and uh can be very valuable
and useful in the organizations you're
working in now this is a a pretty deep
case study so there's a lot of pieces to
it uh we're only going to have about 20
minutes so we're not going to go uh
maybe as as far as you would if you were
taking this as part of a formal program
but it should give you a pretty good
sense of um of what this this would look
like if you were in one of the courses
so uh let me share our screen and we are
going to get started
here now another thing I just want to
bring to your attention I'm going to
shift gears in a little bit and I'm G to
show you a tool called mural and that's
kind of like a online collaborative
whiteboard U makes a little easier kind
of track ideas and it's great for having
other people kind of participate so I'm
going to show that to you as we we build
out and spend a little bit of time uh on
this particular uh case study so here's
the case study this is basically a
document that uh you would reference to
get a better perspective on a real world
uh organizational situation so in this
particular instance we are going to be
talking about big money casinos and this
is a casino that um is responsible for a
large number of casinos around the world
it's a pretty big organization as one
might expect because if you know much
about the casino and the entertainment
industry uh typically these work 7 by 24
7 days a week so they're always in
operation they usually have not just
their casinos but their entertainment as
well as food services and of course A
lot of times are hotels and
accommodations so these are large very
complex uh
environments and one of the things is we
kind of look at uh the context you get a
sense of how big it is you get a sense
of maybe the net revenue but more
importantly what we're interested in
seeing is what challenge are they facing
okay so when we think about introducing
lean practices and behaviors it's
usually because there's a problem okay
there's something that's happening that
we think getting more efficient more
effective at will help us unlock more
value so in this particular instance we
say uh see that this is sort of in the
past 2008 the economic environment for
big money was in serious concern so they
were having some real uh challenges
mostly because there had been this large
you know recession a Great Recession at
that time period and not surprisingly
it's reducing customer spending on
entertainment if you're concerned about
maybe your job or maybe you've lost your
job probably not going to go out to a
casino or some kind of entertainment
environment um and and spend your money
so they're they're struggling with that
so they really want to find a way in
which they can U help minimize the
impact of that decline in revenue and
then in addition we'll see that they
really recognize the importance of
embracing customer service as a really
essential element of their operating
strategy and why is that well if you
think about it if you go to these kind
of uh you know environments you are you
know looking for a positive experience
you want to have fun you're kind of
getting away from from uh your work and
uh and some of your maybe day-to-day
responsibilities and you want to you
know relax and uh enjoy some
entertainment some good food some uh
some some gambling activities so that's
what brings people to these settings so
there's a real interest inuring that
they have a positive customer experience
okay so what I'm going to do is I'm
going to Pivot over to this Tool uh
called mural and I'm going to use this
to kind of track a few ideas that we
want to think about so the first is we
want to make sure we have a clear
understanding of the problem what
problem are we trying to solve so we've
got two segments to this one is we want
to be able to respond to that
macroeconomic you know collapse the
Great Recession impact which is seeing a
decline in revenues and competition for
market share and the second part is to
increase our customer service so we
pivot back to our um case study and I've
taken the time to kind of read a little
bit ahead of this and highlight a few
sections that are relevant for our
conversation today we'll kind of skim
down a little bit but we see that
there's some challenges um one is to the
casino employees they're little
concerned about that word lean they
think lean means cutting jobs which
probably isn't surprising considering
there's this big you know recession
going on so they're legitimately
concerned that when some part of the
organization says hey we're going to get
more efficient their definition of
efficient might be reducing jobs so we
know one of the things we need to do is
we want to ensure that we are make
working with these uh people in the
organization and uh answering their
questions and also helping them
understand this is not about reducing
the headcount this is about uh becoming
more efficient with the work that we're
doing so notice up here one of the first
things that they've recommended we do is
create a regional lean team so let's
think about that uh and also the context
of this idea that lean is might be
associated with cutting jobs so we're
going to form a lean team and what would
a lean team look like well there's
probably a few things we want to give
some thought to one is want to make sure
that the team has a good representation
of different people right so we probably
want uh you know some some leaders some
people who can make good decisions maybe
have some authority to uh make you know
approve uh improvements or to uh spend
money if necessary we also want some of
the U you know individual contributors
these are the people actually doing the
work okay these are folks who are in
maybe on the Casino floors or working in
one of the restaurants um any number of
those kind of roles we want some of the
representation because are the ones
doing the work and we probably want some
you know change Champions some people
that are really passionate about these
ideas saying yeah you know what uh I
think this is a great direction to take
uh what can I do to help promote these
ideas spr the message uh really be part
of the solution so when we think of our
lean team we really want to make sure
that we've got these types of
Representatives on it now uh a good
guide when you're creating any kind of
team is to kind of consider keeping the
team about you know anywhere from five
to 10 people we don't want the team to
get too large because that's going to
bog down its ability to make decisions
and to to kind of operate and function
so once we've got this lean team
established you can see that they're all
kind of centered around this theme of
lean they're going to look at these two
problem statements and they're going to
ask what can we do to make things better
well one of the first things we're
probably going to want the team to
really give some thought to is let's
think about creating a culture a lean
mindset within the
organization okay so this is going to be
really important we want them to give
some thought to um the lean mindset
and make sure that they're U promoting
these ideas explaining to people what
that means maybe reassuring them that to
lean doesn't mean we're cutting jobs it
fact just means we're g to get more
efficient and effective than the work
that we're going to do so we kind of
kind of see lean mindset is sort of a
broad concept that this team is going to
Champion so what would that look like
well they might be developing maybe some
newsletters and Communications that go
out to people uh they could be offering
training uh they could just be providing
support to groups that want to uh spend
more time leveraging these lean
practices now the second part once we
get that lean mind step established we
probably want the lean team to also
start thinking about how are we going to
actually see some of these improvements
emerge and this part becomes really
important because this is where we're
actually going to see the real benefits
of some of these lean practices so we've
got the lean team looking at
situations where they're going to work
with groups to identify where is the
waste occurring hey we're trying to save
as much money as we can because we're
getting our Revenue sort of squeezed
right now so let's find ways we can be
more efficient and effective so let's
take a look back at our case
study and you'll see that um we've got
sorry sp there um a few ideas that have
emerged one is this idea of a f day
Kaizen Workshop now just to bring to
your
attention the whole concept of lean
really has its roots in the Japanese
manufacturing uh industry so this came
out of the 50s there were some U you
know important thought leaders keer duer
and others and they looked at how Japan
was building cars because at the time in
the US the car manufacturing industry
was really lagging they were having a
hard time being competitive with the
cheaper Imports coming from countries
like Japan and Europe and also the
quality of American cars was really kind
of bad uh if you've got you know some
some grandparents uh or uh some some
relatives who might remember that time
period uh there was a time it just you
know you didn't want to buy an American
car because it just was so many issues
and defects that they had and the
Japanese cars were're seen as being very
reliable so there's a lot of interest in
understanding what was the Japanese
solution to this and part of the reason
to bring that up is we're going to hear
a lot of words they're actually Japanese
and Kaizen is an example of one of those
words and Kaizen really is a Japanese
term and I can't say I speak Japanese
when I have some people on the call of
it that do um really talks about making
improvements and the way they make these
improvements is instead of kind of you
know retooling everything and you know
we're going to spend months and change
it all at once it's about making small
micro Pro improvements that over time
add up to really really big impacts so a
big part of that in lean is instilling a
culture of continuous Improvement so
what does that look like well a couple
things we want the people doing the work
to feel empowered that when they see
something that's not efficient or
wasteful that they have you know
confidence that they can go in and make
those changes uh the second thing is we
want to kind of spend time as an
organization focusing on continuous
Improvement we want to encourage
everyone to make sure that they're
spending time thinking about how they
can be more efficient more effective
where do we see unnecessary waste so
what we're seeing here is that they're
proposing a fay Kaizen workshop and this
Workshop is something we can engage with
different teams and look at how they are
working and understand their processes
so we can identify those ways so let's
go back to our um our mural board here
sorry they with me and so we've got
these five days so we know we've got
sort of day one two three four and five
so let me just pop those in
here and then we'll kind of think about
what we're going to do in each of those
five
days and this is the point we're really
kind of getting close to where the work
is occurring right we're going to work
at the team level and we're going to say
hey let's look at how you're
operating and we're going to use that to
better understand how they can
improve okay so I call this sort of a
team Kaizen review and we've got our
lean team and they're going to say hey
we're here to help facilitate these
sessions and we're going to use that as
a place to identify where these these
waste might occur so one of the first
things we need to do when thinking of a
lean Kaizen event is we want to think
about what are we going to do the first
a how do we help people get more
comfortable with these lean Concepts so
um day one we're going to focus on
education we're going to make sure
people understand the reason we want to
spend time on this we want to help them
understand what kind of waste there are
and then uh use that to identify where
those wasts are so a couple things a
little bit interesting about here so
we're going to spend day one on lean
Concepts and we're also going to
introduce this term called down time and
downtime is an acronym which stands for
defects overproduction waiting not
engaging people Transportation inventory
motion and extra
processing so this is day one let's
spend uh kind of pop this into our um
mural so we know what we're dealing with
here
okay so we put that there and we'll call
this day
one he get people introduced to Concepts
like downtime and what else we're going
to do where we're going to educate
people on lean Concepts so so that's the
the starting point for our Kaizen
Workshop all right so once we've got
that in place we've got a good
understanding of sort of what the intent
of lean is uh this is also going to help
broaden that lean mindset awareness
across the whole organization each time
we work with a team uh they're going to
go through this process each team's
going to leave with a better
understanding of the lean mindset
they're also going to have this set of
techniques where they can identify where
there are waste and what kind of waste
are we thinking about well every
organization is going to be a little bit
different this is of course dealing with
sort of the um you know customer service
and uh sort of entertainment space so
some examples of defx might be um uh
delivering a drink to a customer with
ice when they ask for no ice well that's
a defect right because you're going to
have to go take that drink back refill
it bring it back to the guest You'
wasted some time or maybe a guest
checking into a hotel room that has the
wrong bed typ they ask for two queen
beds and instead they got a king-sized
bed so now you've got to kind of unbook
them from that room find a room that has
a king size bed uh so that adds a lot of
time and it also gives a poor impression
of that customer experience you can see
examples through the rest of this things
like over production what would over
production look like in this kind of
environment well maybe when you're
serving water it comes with a slice a
lemon slice to kind of give some flavor
to the water but we you know the servers
are providing three lemon slices and you
might think ah what's a couple extra
lemon slices but once you multiply that
by Poss tens of thousands of drink
orders every single day that adds up
pretty quickly so we want to find ways
in which we can uh limit the amount of
over production we do another is waiting
anytime there's waiting you're waiting
for something where employees are Idol
or a customer is waiting for the service
is a form of waste who wants to to wait
right it's not a fun experience no one
enjoys that so we really want to be on
the lookout for anytime we're seeing our
valuable people and our customers
waiting and find ways in which we can
kind of um provide them the service more
quickly uh not engaging people so this
is really important in a customer
service domain we want to make sure that
we're spending time actually connecting
with the people um you know making sure
that uh you know when we're trying to uh
move something like a a food cart and
it's going across a deep pile Carpeting
and corridors it leads to not just
longer time to get that food to where
needs to go to but it makes the
employees pushing that tired uh
transportation is another one we want to
make sure that the work that people are
doing U minimizes the amount of
Transportation required so we want to
make sure for example if you're working
in in the restaurant area you're
providing drinks if every time an order
comes in you have to run away to all the
way to the back of the kitchen to uh
maybe fill up water glasses and bring
that back to your tray that you take out
maybe we should move the water
um station closer to where staff are
coming into the kitchen reduce the
amount of Transportation uh inventory is
another good example A lot of times
organizations have excess inventory and
excess inventory in and of itself is um
is waste it's not something we can do
anything with it's just sitting there
getting Obsolete and a lot of times that
inventory just gets thrown out if it it
becomes too old so they have an example
where each team the team was ordering
$110,000 worth of slot paper for their
slot machines regardless of what
inventory they have they're just putting
in the order consistently but when
demand went down suddenly they had this
increasing amount of slot paper that was
available on the floor and of course
that required more storage and the slot
paper often would become obsolete if
they changed anything on on what was
required to be printed we talked a
little bit about motion as well want to
find ways in which reduce the amount of
motion that people are performing like
you know things like getting water or
getting napkins or things like that and
then extra processing this basically
refers to anytime uh we're doing work
that is nonv value added in this example
they talk about uh they had security
guards who' use metal detecting wands to
scan bags of trash coming out of the
cash Counting Room uh to make sure that
there are no coins that are being
smuggled out but at some point the
casino eliminated metal coins from
operations they only used plastic coins
so waving the metal Wand Over the
garbage bags doesn't make a lot of sense
because you're never going to find any
of that so those are some examples of
how we can use that acronym downtime to
identify the different types of waste
that might occur in an operation like
that so once we've got kind of a good
feel of you know what waste is and why
it's important to remove and we can
identify the different types of wayte
then we want to do something called a
gmba walk and again this is another
Japanese term gima in this case means
sort of walking around so why do we want
to do that well we want to get close to
where the work is being done to really
understand what's happening so this is
something where that team with people
they've been training would go out onto
the floors into the work areas where the
team operates and give them give them a
little visibility to what's actually
going on and we'd use that to identify
some areas where we see some improvement
opportunities so that's day two we're
going to walk around and uh get some
um more visibility to the the type of
work that is being performed see if I
can make this at least the same color so
we're a little bit
consistent okay so we'll spend time on
day two kind of walking around checking
out what's going on in the
environment okay and then in day
three what are we going to do well we're
going to kind of look at these
observations and you can see some
examples you get yellow stick stickies
you kind of map out the process who does
what where there might be dependencies
you get the people doing the work to
give you this visibility and let them
discover where the wastes are where the
inefficiencies are and once youve got a
good sense of you know how you could
improve things um you might look at you
know redesigning the location of work
items so it's easier to get to and this
is called a spaghetti diagram here if
you can see my screen it just shows
where people are going from one place to
the next so you can say oh there a lot
of traffic going way to the back let's
move those items a little closer to
where they're needed um we might need to
prioritize waste maybe you're going to
see lots and lots of waste so you got to
ask well which things are the most
important what are the things that we
think if we remove now will have bigger
impact later on so in day three we're
going to look at the root cause of all
the waste we're going to ask ourselves
what are the things that um we want to
do differently so we can remove that
waste and one of the things you're going
to use is some techniques like uh 5s and
that's a technique that is used quite a
bit in these settings uh the S is
actually in this case Latin don't ask me
why we're switched from Japanese to
Latin but the uh the s in this case is
really asking um some some fundamental
questions about um why things are
sitting where they are and in fact
another really powerful technique is the
five y's and what we do in five y's is
we just ask the question
why five times and that can be pretty
powerful because you know they have an
example here um why do attendons spend
four hours a day polishing clean
silverware so the silverware has been
clean and the the tendons have to spend
four hours of each day each one of them
polishing it why well because it has
spots and that doesn't look acceptable
on our dining table why does it have
spots well because when it comes out of
the dishwasher it has spots on it why
does the dishwasher leave spots in the
silverware well it's because the
dishwasher doesn't hold a consistent
temperature during one of the phases
cleaning cycle H why why does that
cleaning cycle not hold a consistent
temperature well it's because the
preventive maintenance protocol is not
being um maintained to the manufacturer
recommendations okay so now we know the
root cause so what can we do to fix it
well let's bring things back up to the
maintenance protocol and by fixing that
we don't have the spots anymore and it
frees up 4 hours a day for our
attendance cleaning that silverware so
that's an example of some root cause
analysis we do okay so once we've got
some ideas of what the root cause is now
we can come up Solutions on how we can
fix those root causes so that's day four
we're going to dig into um the
U potential Solutions
here
and we'll just add day four here now
we've got solutions that are going to
make it easier for us to uh fix these
problems and um once we've you know had
some of these brainstorming and this is
where we use a concept of the five s's
which stand for
um Siri
saton suitsu and shaki oh sorry they are
Japanese my bad I thought they were
Latin previously but U basically it
means sort set in order shine
standardize and sustain and what does
that mean well um you're going to sort
first off let's look at all the things
we have maybe you got a big inventory
room uh where we've been accumulating a
lot of inventory over many years um if
and doubt throw it out take a look at
everything things that are unnecessary
let's get them out of the way because
they make it hard to find the things
that are necessary so get rid of all the
out ofate orders we'll set in order
we'll make sure everything's got a place
for everything and everything in its
place so make sure it's easy to find the
things that you need have clearly marked
labels on them all shine let's make sure
we clean and inspect the workplace make
sure everything's thoroughly cleaned
neat and functioning properly um
standardized make sure we create an
enforce policies and procedures that
make this a daily practice not a
one-time event remember we talked about
continuous Improvement and this Su same
how do we make sure we institutionalize
this so people do it all the time that's
part of that lean mindset so we'll uh
kind of add these techniques to what we
do on day four when we're kind of
brainstorming or you might have seen the
term try storming let's just try doing
things a little bit different so we can
make things
better but once we've kind of gone
through this exercise and you can see
some pictures from before and after
here's one of the inventory storage
rooms it you know looks like boxes are
just stacked a little bit irregularly
and they've restructured it we've got
clear labels at the top we've got things
stacked up appropriately you immediately
visually can see where you might be
running low on certain items maybe where
you have excess inventory you don't need
to order more of the items that perhaps
are stacked up a little
higher now finally once we're we're
finished all this um a few things that
you know you should be aware of this
activity this kaisen process is so
impactful they can often eliminate
almost 90% of the waste observations
that it made so think about that for a
second you go in and within five days
you can remove 90% of the waste so this
is an incredibly valuable investment a
lot of it's just driven by common sense
right we're not doing anything you know
really un out of the ordinary here we're
just kind of looking how we're working
and asking some questions and how we can
be more efficient and we're really
giving the people doing the work the
opportunity to to identify where those
improvements are and finally what we
want to do on day five we want to take
the findings and we want to present them
back to our leadership our customers
kind of show them hey we've spent time
on this this is what we come up with as
some improvements and um get their
support if necessary um and also help
them recognize that this has really
saved time and improved
operations so a big part of this as
hopefully you're you're picking out
we've looked at this case study we've
got an organization that was in trouble
right they're struggling with revenue
and they need to get more efficient and
effective with their cost management so
this is really the foundation of our
lean culture we really want to ensure
that we understand how we're operating
that we introduce some kpi some key
performance indicators so we get a
better understanding of how we're
working together and make sure that we
are solving problems as we discover them
so we can eliminate this waste so we can
probably take this little picture here
okay we'll pop it in maybe
here it went maybe it's a little
difficulty pacing this in try one more
time
um cut it let see if that
helps well maybe it's not going to work
today um but we really that lean um view
should be our house of lean we want to
create this whole culture that
recognizes that lean and and waste
removal is everyone's responsibility so
one of the things that we want to take
away from this is so what were the
results well within a little over a year
U this organization conducted 60 of
these Kaizen events they went to 60
different teams with more than 400
employees 14,000 hours put into this and
they saw some pretty significant results
might remember the very beginning of
this it talked about the fact that they
saved over $3
million in ongoing savings so that's
pretty powerful right because you're
getting that 3 million not just now but
every year that goes forward so it kind
of compounds on itself so what we can
see is um some of the results that we
have here and I kind of pop them into
the test uh sort of this area so these
are the the outcomes that we want to
kind of track and
measure and um let me just put that term
there because that's an important thing
we want to focus on we really want to
ensure that we're getting outcomes we
getting real value from the work that
we're
doing okay so these are the outcomes
that came from this and what were some
of those outcomes well let's take
ourselves back to our um presentation
here there were five key things that we
really walked around around away with
first is creating that lean mindset we
created a lean team to help communicate
and promote the lean mindset of how to
remove waste we recognize that actions
speak louder than words so we don't just
want to tell people to do this we want
to go in and help them do this how do we
do that those five-day Kaizen workshops
we made sure senior leaders were aware
of what was going on so there'd be
supportive of it and theyd free up the
time necessary for the teams to do these
Kaizen work shops make sure employees
are involved we really want to get the
people doing the work engaged and part
of this uh activity and then keep it
simple me a lot of this wasn't super
complicated right it was about things
like hey let's reduce the amount of time
we're polishing silverware let's get
better at organizing our inventory Let's
uh make sure that we're not you know you
know booking uh people for the wrong
rooms and if we are let's ask those five
y's on what we can do to kind of
identify the root cause of of the
problems so all told this is kind of an
example now again I went through this
pretty quickly uh but hopefully you can
get a little sense of the flow we had a
problem statement we had uh we kind of
organized a team we promoted this
mindset we did these kaen reviews and
then we got these outcomes these are the
results that are going to help the
organization uh continue to succeed and
we can quantify those there's $3 million
put back in your pocket uh that that's
going to help
make sure we can get through this
difficult time to a point where the
economy recovers and people continue to
come out to these casinos going forward
so actually I think that's it uh might
have got a little over than our original
time but uh hopefully this helpful and
if you've got some questions pop those
into the Q&A and we'll get to those um
as soon as we wrap up the session here
that was really insightful Brian even I
learned a thing and I am sure our
audience did too I would request the
audience uh to post your questions in in
the Q&A box so that we can take it up as
we go along
uh thank you Brian uh I'll quickly share
my screen
again so that's what we what we learned
from our session today uh moving on uh
so this is what just one of the projects
that we will be coming across your
course uh the post graduate program in
the in lining Sigma uh so one quick Co
po we have for our audience uh what's
really stopping you from becoming a lean
6 Sigma expert I'll quickly launch the
poll
uh uh are you unable to find a program
which which has a completely
comprehensive curriculum or is it that
you don't have enough practical exposure
to become job ready uh are you finding
it difficult to learn from pre-recorded
videos or your work schedule just
doesn't allow you enough time to learn
uh I would request all of you to punch
in your uh answers and we'll be
answering your queries
shortly I'll keep the poll open for
another 10 seconds I would request all
of you to punch in your
answers great great great great thank
you all for the responses I'll end the
poll
now so as I can see uh Brian uh people
here majority the 50% of our audience
says that they don't have enough
practical exposure I'm glad we had this
session today where people got a taste
of what the program actually entails uh
a live project demo and let me remind
the audience that this is just one of
the projects that you'll be going
through in your curriculum there are
about 15 more projects which you can go
through and three Capstone projects as
well which you can uh work on and add it
to your portfolio
and so now that we have your answers uh
we would like to introduce our program
the postgraduate program in lan6 Sigma
which has a comprehensive curriculum
with an industry aligned learning path
it has case studies Hands-On projects uh
one of them which you just went AC uh
went through and we also have simulated
tests for practical experience we also
conduct online live virtual classrooms
with p and instructor interaction uh and
it's really flexible which will fit into
your lifestyle and schedule so this
program if you invest about 5 to 10
hours a week you'll be able to complete
in the period of six months this program
is brought to you by UMAS the University
of Massachusetts amher and it's powered
by KPMG the content provider is
obviously our business publishing
education coming to the program benefits
uh you'll be getting the UMAS amers
postgraduate program certification it
will have 150 hours of Applied learning
we will you will be going through three
Harvard case studies 17 Hands-On
projects one of which you went through
just now and about 18 simulation exams
we will have three Capstone projects
which will help you uh materialize
whatever you learn throughing the course
and uh apply them in real world projects
you'll also earn 122 uh credits to your
continuing certification requirements we
will have master classes from our
University of massachusett Amherst and
even senior Consultants from
KPMG you will be given the alumni
membership of umast MH and you'll also
have access to nine credits which are
transferable to the online MBA program
provided by UMAS SST coming to the UMAS
MERS Advantage we all know that UMAS is
a 130y old Institution
when has been consistently ranking the
in one of the top us
universities post the program will give
you the C you must am has certificates
and along with the master classes and
you'll be all you'll be preparing for
the lean Six Sigma Green Belt and Black
Belt certification we got a question on
similar lines how do we get a lean Six
Sigma Green Belt and Black Belt
certification this program will
certainly help you prepare for these
exams and clear them
and having the UMAS or amher
certification on your CV will be
recognized
worldwide coming to the KPMG Advantage
this course is powered by KPMG KPMG as
we all know is one of the big for
consulting firms with the presence of
over 140 countries we will have senior
KPMG Consultants who will give you the
correct guidance training and mentoring
throughout the
course I would request Brian to take us
through through the different steps
where in the course which will help our
Learners have a comprehensive learning
part sure sure so um yeah as you can see
the sort of follows a very uh structured
and uh well organized approach we're
going to start with getting everyone
comfortable with these concepts of lean
management you just got a little flavor
of them in the demo that we just did
once you're comfortable that we're going
to shift you into leveraging some agile
practices lean and agile fit together
very very well um agile really looks at
reducing waste as we're delivering value
so it Partners nicely with the whole
lean management structure so we're going
to get you some uh skills in that space
particular with practices like scrum and
conon and extreme programming and test
driven development all those are really
really powerful techniques and tools
that you can apply in your work
environment then we're going to give you
some exposure to some tooling this
product called called mini tab is a
statistical tool and a lot of times we
have to look at large sets of data and
use that to understand what is sort of
the average performance and then
understand what we can do to kind of
improve that then we can um progress
into improving and increasing our lean
Six Sigma skills through practical
application so we've got our lean Six
Sigma Green Belt lan6 Sigma Black Belt
those are just progressions you start
Green Belt then you move to Black Belt
each one building on the other and
that's going to give you an opportunity
to apply these techniques in real world
settings using some of the uh examples
that we heard actually talk about all
those different you know real world
project program examples uh then we're
going to shift into digital
transformation this is a really
important concept that is uh being
embraced by organizations and industries
across the world how can they shift to
more digital delivery and the reason
that's important because digital
delivery allows them to become much much
more efficient okay instead of having
people moving pieces of paper around
typing things in manually many times we
try and shift all that to kind of a
digital environment and then it makes it
easier for organizations to kind of
pivot and shift and respond to market
demand finally we'll wrap things up with
that lean Six Sigma Capone project an
example which we just spend a little
time on uh you're going to go very deep
into this you're going to get a chance
to really apply all the skills that
you've learned through the program and
then you're going to exit it with this
really powerful example of how you apply
those tools and techniques that have
been mentored by one of the coaches in
the program so you can showcase this to
your existing employer or future
employers great great thank you Brian
moving on these are some of the program
icons we have already discussed uh
you'll be learning the different waste
fighting measures of inan practices
eliminate the root causes of defects and
waste understanding sigma's dmac phases
the is Define measure analyze improve
and control uh you can become a key
stakeholder in leading implementing SC
six projects in organization and we
already discussed the FES was production
process
planning uh these are some of the tools
that you'll be mastering during the
course the tmac agile PM V6 L6 Sigma and
the tools as well min mini tab J office
and
project these are some of the projects
you'll be working on during the course
uh these are Harvard case studies and
projects one of them we already
discussed uh and they'll be apart from
these four there will be many many more
which you can put your Implement your
skills on as
well as we already discussed you'll be
going through some of the capson
projects which will obviously enhance
your CVS and which will be you will be
able to Showcase to your future
employers and get that interview you are
always looking
for and at the end end of the end of all
you'll be having the postgraduate
certification as I already mentioned
you'll be receiving nine credits
transferable to an online MBA as well
and you'll be having the Amur Alumni
Association membership and we'll also
help you prepare for the link ex Green
Belt as well as the black belt
certifications uh we have some of the
global leaders as program advisers uh
including Alan Robinson he's the
operations management professor in
University of Massachusetts uh Michelle
B she's a senior lecturer in the
institution as
well coming to the eligibility criteria
of this program uh you may uh it's not
necessary to have a programming
background you can have any background
and you will be uh you need to have a
bachelor's degree in any discipline and
you need to have a minimum of five years
of experience to enroll in this
program so now that you have understood
the various projects and skills that
you'll be taking up we would like to run
a quick poll to understand if you will
be interested in enrolling for this
program I will quickly launch the poll
so that you can punch in your
answers great great great great I'll
keep the poll open for another five
seconds please pun chin here
say it's a simple yes or no I'll end the
poll
now as I can see over 60% of our
audience is already interested in
enrolling for the program and that's
great moving on I'll quickly run you
through the enrollment steps we have
three simple steps the first step
involves you need to send an application
uh which will be uh you will need to
send an email to the email ID mentioned
below here ask us at simply learn.net
uh and once you have subed the
application or team will be reviewing
the application uh regarding your
background and your work experience once
the application is approved you'll be
getting an admission letter from Lumas
amst uh if some if any of you guys are
interested in enrolling right away our
next cohort starts on the October 28th
and for which the induction class will
be held on the October 23rd and the
batch will begin on October 28th the
coming to the pricing we have priced it
at a reasonable
$22.99 for us candidates and uh about
$7,999 plus GST to the candidates in
India if you have any further questions
regarding we also have uh Emi options
for our candidates so if you have are
interested please send in your requests
and emails to ask us at simply land.net
and let me also inform you that we have
limited seats for for every cohort uh
you'll be able to get more details on
our website as
well so now that you know
uh now that you know the schedule and I
would like to uh run a quick poll again
uh how soon do you plan to enroll for
this program it may be immediately uh
within six months within six
3 months or more than six months from
now so we would like to just punch in
your
answers I'll keep the poll open for
another five seconds I would request all
of you to punch in your
answers great great great thank you all
for your
responses
coming to the questions uh we have a few
questions Brian uh I would just quickly
shoot them to
you sure yeah I can see we've already
answered some of the questions how do I
get a green and black belt obviously
this program will help you prepare for
these exams and uh you
can uh so we have a question Brian what
are the similar ities or differences
between lean and
agile right yeah so lean and agile pair
together very very well so lean is about
removing reducing waste and that's
something agile emphasizes a lot if
you've used agile practices before
things like retrospectives there an
opportunity for the team to kind of ask
what worked well what can we do better
how can we improve so a lot of times we
consider lean and agile kind of being
the same in fact a lot of organizations
call it lean agile for that that very
reason thank
[Music]
you so uh we have another question uh
what are the differences between the
belts like uh green primary difference
is simply that the the green belt sort
of a starter you know you're learning
and applying black belt you're just
applying more skills getting more in
depth in the analysis so it's just a
progression thank you
so uh we'll have one last question here
uh Brian how difficult is green belt and
the other
exams well I will say they're um they're
they're challenging uh you're not going
to uh be able to get through them
without um preparing uh you'll
absolutely need to have some course um
support so going through courses like
this uh then you're going to have a um
combination of an online exam and you'll
have to show an example of work that you
completed that supports these lean
practices so uh yeah it's pretty
comprehensive but this is part of the
reason organizations really look for
people who can prove that they have
these skills and they've earned these
certifications so the nice thing about
this program is the partnership with
simper and the University of
Massachusetts is they give you the
support you need so you can get these
certifications and show that you've got
these
skills great great thank you thank you
uh there's one question from Ravi I will
just take it up does one have to
complete Black Belt also to in order to
get um certificate Ravi no uh you'll be
uh once you enroll for this program you
uh you'll be able to prepare for the
green belt and black belt
certifications uh it's not necessary to
complete Black Belt in order to get a
Uma certificate if I a question
correctly thank you all uh that's it uh
if I apologize we are not able to answer
any of your questions I would request
you to shoot your questions and
applications to ask us at simply
learn.net I've also posted
the uh course page link on on the chat
you can access I'll post it
again and you can access our course page
for more details of the program and you
can always send in an inquiry and our
team will get back to you one last poll
we have uh if you need any assistance to
enroll I will quickly launch the poll so
those who have uh expressed their
interest in enrolling for the program if
you need any kind of assistance to get
enrolled for this program we will be
more than happy to help you please punch
in your answers in the
poll I'll just keep this open for
another few seconds and I close
the thank you all for your responses uh
those who have answered yes in this poll
our team will be getting back to you as
soon as possible and we'll be helping
you with the further process of
enrollment and uh with that I would like
to thank our Mentor for today Brian uh
it was a really insightful session the
project demo and we really learned
something and if I would request the
audience if you are willing
to learn even more such insightful
projects we would really love you to see
on the Learning Community uh I have
already posted the link uh you can
always visit our website and enroll for
the program I would like to thank Brian
Brian it was a really in insightful
session yes thanks so much it was great
spending some time with everyone and I
did pop a few uh responses few your
questions in the chat as well so maybe
take a look at that before you sign off
and uh OE hope you have a wonderful
evening looking forward to our next
session together and thanks everyone
have a great rview day thank you all for
joining us today I will end the webinar
now thank you have a nice great day take
care